hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar see when your aav can't stand
the heat with uncle
i am kaylee bach of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by unchained labs to learn more
please visit unchainedlabs.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
kevin lance director of analytics
marketing at unchainedlabs
kevin you may now begin your
presentation
welcome to my talk see when your aav
can't stand the heat with uncle
lundgren labs has been helping out with
our gene therapy squad for all kinds of
problems and all kinds of gene therapy
tech we've been honing our tools to
deliver answers and save boatloads of
time for aav and other viruses
stunner quickly delivers answers on
tighter and empty flow ratio big tuna
takes care of buffer exchange and
concentration and uncle is the key to
all kinds of stability insights that's
exactly what we'll be checking out today
for aav
this is one way to think about aav if we
think of aav as a pinata that dna candy
and the caps it is cardboard and colored
paper
that everyone wants a lot of information
about that aav
and current analytical methods aren't
good enough but uncle helps you know
exactly how stable your av is and how to
help stop aggregation from becoming a
problem
so if we keep thinking of av as a pinata
then this is what a thermal stability
experiment looks like
uncle is that broadsword-wielding
warrior who is wasting no time seeing
what this capsid can withstand
meanwhile gene therapy researchers are
there in the background
cheering on the experiment and excited
for the results
so let's learn a little bit about uncle
uncle is an all-in-one stability
platform ready for aav
it uses two lasers to excite either
label free capsid protein intrinsic
fluorescence or a variety of dye based
fluorescents we'll actually use both
fluorescence methods to look at aev
stability
with full spectrum fluorescence
detection alkal can pick up on both side
kinds of those signals which is really
valuable
sls is the scattered light from those
two lasers and gives information on when
aggregates form during especially during
a thermal stability ramp
dls is dynamic light scattering and
allows for detailed measurements of size
and size distribution
those three detection methods can be
operated isothermally or across a heat
ramp designed to thermally stress
samples and see which ones can take the
heat
that means uncle is able to deliver
results on aggregation and two different
looks
on viral caps stability in about two
hours with only nine microliters of
sample for up to 48 samples at a time
the secret sauce of the uncle is the uni
it's an anodized aluminum frame with 16
quarts cuvettes where each quartz
cuvette holds 9 microliters of sample so
all you do is pipette in your sample and
seal the unit inside of its blue frame
so silicon seals clip around those
little cuvettes
just like that you have a nicely sealed
sample where you don't have to worry
about evaporation over long periods of
time or over a thermal round
this is also a handy sample holder
because you can pop it into say a 37
degree incubator and do a weeks or
months long stability experiment right
in the uni or you could put it into a
freezer and go through freeze thaw
cycles also right in that uni
those are some advantages to having a
well-sealed sample holder with such a
small sample volume needed
okay so coming back to aav
uncle can deliver two different kinds of
stability information when it comes to
aav capsule stability and aggregation
when it comes to capsid stability uncle
will use its fluorescence to measure two
different behaviors
on top you see a cartoon of protein
unfolding and capsid disruption
occurring as a result
or on the bottom of the left side of the
slide
genome injection can actually occur from
mostly intact capsules sometimes called
uncoding but since this is happening
outside of cells i prefer to call it
genome injection
so we'll look at data both from the
literature and from uncle to demonstrate
those behaviors and investigate them
further
on the right side of the slide
we'll talk about aggregation which with
uncle's sls and dls capabilities they'll
be able to identify when aggregation
occurs which can be either at time zero
before an experiment
where you want to check out that your
sample is monodispersed and to know if
you should go forward with your
experiment
or with sls you can see how aggregation
occurs during a thermal ramp as a
measure of the colloidal stability of
your
aav
so the first question to address usually
is how do we know that aav capsids have
these two different stability options
for sort of falling apart the capsid
disruption and the genome injection
pathway
well before that we go to the literature
here we can see three different
morphologies of aav in an afm data set
done on aav8 maybe 9.
these afm images show both behaviors
directly
in this case the afm data were captured
after heating av to various temperatures
so at the top we can see intact capsid
says bright circles
and going down the slide to the green
boxes we can see those bright white
circles with ejected dna
coming out of each one of them
the authors of this paper also point out
that the length of dna exiting the
capsids is variable and so that supports
the idea uh that this dna is in the
process of exiting the capsid
on the bottom is compact dna clusters
without those aav bright white circles
or capsids so this is what
would be left behind after complete aav
disruption
so in this one data set you can see
sort of all three states of aav both the
intact capsid form the form where it's
sort of pseudostable and ejecting its
linearized dna and then the finally
totally disruption
pile of dna form
all right so so check out caps and
stability uncle will make use of the
intrinsic fluorescence of the aav
captive proteins
uncle's going to excite those caps of
proteins with its 266 nanometer laser
and the tryptophan and tyrosine residues
of those proteins will then fluoresce
when those proteins unfold that
fluorescence changes in a few
characteristics characteristic ways and
lets us know
unfolding has occurred
here we have a quick look at the
intrinsic fluorescence signal collected
by uncle on a sample of 1 times 10 to
the 13th aav9
without cybergold
each line here is a fluorescence rate at
a different temperature starting from
top and going to the bottom
as the sample temperature increases the
signal intensity drops and shifts to the
right which is called a redshift
so that blue arrow and dashed line i'm
going to guide the eye to this red shift
by showing you where the true vertical
is and then showing you where the
peak of each of those distributions is
also note that you can see the sls
signal from both the 266 nanometer and
the 473 nanometer lasers
on this fluorescence trace
so if we take that same intrinsic
fluorescence data
and we analyze it to look for the sort
of spectral center of mass also called
the barycentric mean wavelength of bcm
wavelength and we have the data shown in
blue so as you heat up the aav sample
at a certain point those proteins start
to show that red shift and that bcn
wavelength increases we can identify the
onset temperature for that increase here
at 74.2 degrees celsius and the melting
temperature for that unfolding behavior
here at 78.6 degrees
at the same time by tracking the sls
signal from the 266 nanometer laser we
can see aggregation behavior because
when av is just floating around happily
that sls signal will be quite stable but
once aggregation has begun that sls
signal increases so you can see in green
that sls 266 signal
increases with the tag or aggregation
temperature at 74.5 degrees
so with this one run we're able to look
at both
protein capsid unfolding and aggregation
through the means of looking at
simultaneous fluorescence and sls
for genome ejection uncle will make use
of cyber gold dye and will excite cyber
gold with its 473 nanometer laser
and the purpose of adding that dye is to
detect genome ejection
by showing an increase in fluorescent
signal so at the start cyber gold will
have a low fluorescence well the genome
is inside of the capsid but any free dna
will show fluorescence
but as the capsid is heated and releases
dna then that fluorescence of cyber gold
will increase because the cyber will die
and the dna can now interact with each
other
the temperature where the dye
fluorescence increases will be the
stability readout
so here we have a sample of 1 times 10
to the 13th aav9 with cyber gold where
we can see the dye's fluorescence in a
different part of the spectrum from the
intrinsic protein fluorescence
so that's between about 500 and 650
nanometers where that fluorescent signal
increase as temperature goes up
we also see the sls peak at 473
nanometers
but in this experiment only that 473
nanometer blue laser is used
so that's why there's no intrinsic
fluorescence signal or a sls signal at
266 nanometers
here's a look at the analysis
for that cyber gold fluorescence again
we're looking at fluorescence in green
but this time it's the area under the
curve
so the headline of this experiment uh
will be that large increase that you see
but let's walk through it from left to
right
so starting at room temperature at 25
degrees celsius
what we first noticed is that there's
some signal from
existing free-floating dna uh
present with cyber gold dive and our aav
sample
so that's the kind of thing that we can
purify out with benzene step followed by
a molecular wave cut off
buffer exchange or dialysis or running
on the big tuna
as temperature increases
what we see is
first that cyber fluorescence decreases
because there is a relationship between
temperature and cervical fluorescence
but starting about 50 degrees celsius we
see a large increase in fluorescence and
identified melting temperature about 58
degrees celsius
so this is that headline of the
experiment showing the ejection of viral
dna at those temperatures
consistent with
literature data that we'll see a little
bit
forward in the experiment and also with
that afm data that we showed earlier
simultaneous with this cyber gold
fluorescence ejection
we're also looking at the sls data in
blue and this is showing our
aggregation onset again really close to
75 degrees celsius so with one
experiment we're seeing the
amount of dna that's present at the
start of the experiment before any aev
have started to degrade because of
temperature
we're seeing the temperature at which
dna starts to release from our capsids
and we're seeing when
aggregation begins by sls
as we read tons of samples on the uncle
we've noticed that each serotype behaves
very differently so here i've shown a
series where we've mixed together
empty and full capsules for aav5 on the
right maybe 9 on the left
what you can see is
a couple of different
observations
first aav9 shows uh sort of a
bimodal
genome ejection behavior
but that first peak between about 40 50
degrees celsius is rather weak and then
most genome ejection appears to occur
between 50 and 60 degrees celsius
contrasts that with aav5 and you see a
much more clear
behavior where you get a lot of genome
injection occurring between 40 and 50
degrees celsius and a little bit less
occurring at higher temperatures you
also notice that for both of these
samples as we increase
the or as we increase the number of
empty capsids or decrease the percent
full present in the sample
that the signal coming from cyber gold
also decreases which is what you expect
because hey there's less dna present in
the sample
if you check out a couple more
interesting stereotypes you can see the
extremes of these
aggregation and genome injection
behaviors
where on the left we're looking at
php.eb and at the right we're looking at
ancient 80 and you'll notice
these are are
pretty unique in that they're at extreme
ends of the spectrum for the stereotypes
that we've tested so with php.eb
the aggregation temperature lines up
exactly with the genome injection
temperature
but with ancient 80 it's actually the
largest difference between those two
behaviors that we've seen where there's
a 30 degree celsius gap between the
genome ejection and aggregation
behaviors
and importantly that something that we
saw earlier is that that aggregation
behavior
always syncs up with the protein
unfolding behavior
from the capsid so even though we're not
looking directly at the protein behavior
with this blue laser and cybergold dye
we can infer where protein unfolding
occurs because that will also line up
with the onset of aggregation
if we want to check out going beyond
amino acid sequence and serotypes we can
look at excipients and formulation where
here we're looking at the intrinsic
fluorescence and protein unfolding on
the left and the cyber gold fluorescence
and genome injection on the right
in green we have a pbs sample and in
blue we've spiked an arginine into the
buffer of that sample
so
here that high concentration arginine
spike decreases the protein stability
fluorescence
by about seven degrees but actually
decreases the genome ejection stability
about 13 degrees celsius so that tells
us a couple of things
first of all that formulations do impact
both stability behaviors
and that they impact those stability
behaviors to varying extents so it's
important to measure both stability
behaviors uh which you can do very
nicely and easily on the uncle
you can't just look at one and see that
it's a seven degree c difference and
extrapolate that to the other behavior
it's something that you do need to get
both data points independently
okay
so now we know we can crack open the av
pinata let's also take a look at what
you can do to change how things come
apart with a look further look at the
impact of formulations
so we'll take a quick pit stop in the
literature to get something to compare
this with so in this paper by bennett a
variety of buffers were tested and it's
apparent that the choice of buffer
has an impact on protein unfolding
and aav stability so here i'm
highlighting av serotypes 289 because
we'll check those out on uncle a little
bit later in this case the authors are
using a dsf method using cypher orange
dye
that does look specifically at the
protein unfolding behavior of aav
capsids so we'll be comparing our
protein intrinsic
stability to those different data points
shown by bennett
okay so to set this experiment up what
we did was use big tuna to buffer
exchange those three serotypes 289
into a variety of buffers that span a
variety of ph's and we're doing this uh
in a 96 well format plate with a 10 kilo
dollar molecular weight cutoff filter so
after that buffer exchange we then read
those samples on uncle to screen for
their impact on capsid stability and
genome ejection
so first let's start with capsule
stability and protein unfolding
on the left we have aav2 and on the
right we have aav9
so what we're seeing here is we're
checking out exactly when proteins start
to unfold in response to
uh
to increase thermal stress
so with aav2 we're seeing starting with
pbs at ph 7.4
the earliest unfolding of those caps of
proteins and then as we get more acidic
in our ph you start to see later in
later protein unfolding
and you notice that covers quite a large
spread of aav behavior of cross
temperatures
meanwhile on the right side of the slide
in aav9
at those same four ph's
we see
unfolding of those proteins at very high
temperature and they're also very
closely bunched together
so
very different behavior based on aav
serotype
if we plot for our three serotypes
the
data where we're looking at different
buffers and trying to understand how
they behave what we can see is this
relationship between buffer ph and
melting temperature of the capsid
proteins
and just to the left of each graph
what we can do is again add in that data
from bennett and see that ph is a really
nice tool that can take
aav stability across the the same range
of
stabilities that bennett saw in their
buffer screen
so
this can be one way to start to
understand how your aav might behave
once it gets inside of
cells and it's inside of a late endosome
does
do those proteins start to
change their stability behavior and
likewise you can use it to optimize the
buffer that they're being stored in to
make sure that they're going to hold on
to their
caps approach and stability as long as
possible
okay let's shift gears and look at the
other half of the equation for genome
ejection
and here we're just looking at aav2 and
seeing the impact of uh different
acetate buffers at three different ph's
and you can see at
uh actually more acidic phs
that now we have genome ejection
behavior uh that is sort of more stable
so it's occurring at higher temperatures
in those more acidic phs
and if we kind of wrap everything up in
one nice graph what we can do is check
out our auv2 sample and look at various
different ph's and see uh that ph has
uh very interesting effects on
on both capsule stability and genome
ejection
so by running these samples on uncle in
just a couple of hours we can get a very
complete look at aav stability and
understand
how changes in ph impact both our
protein unfolding through intrinsic
fluorescence and a look at the capsule
stability
and how it impacts our genome ejection
behavior of aav and understanding when
our
viral vector might release its dna into
the surrounding environment
which could be useful both in terms of
buffer storage and in terms of
how it behaves in the late endosome of
the cells
and also importantly i want to emphasize
that this whole experiment took about 24
hours a day of experimental time so that
buffer exchange on big tuna had just a
couple of hours and then two rounds on
uncle uh with one of them overnight and
we were done with this whole experiment
data set
pretty fast
so from all that uncle data and academic
literature we can see that these two
different stability behaviors happen at
different temperatures with genome
ejection actually occurring at
temperatures far below capsid disruption
and so this is why measuring viral
stability and uncle is so important it
can look at both of these pieces of data
and aggregation too and understand
exactly what's going on with your av
sample
so with this data you can hopefully
create an aav that's ready for battle
and won't aggregate or fall apart when
under stress
thanks for your kind attention and now
pause and take questions but if anyone
has any other questions they want to
reach out to us you can find us at info
enchantlabs.com
thank you kevin for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks do these stereotypes have
different aggregation behavior
yes so definitely and i would also
probably add
definitely
so if you're looking at aggregation
there's probably two different ways that
you can look at that one is if you just
have a sample you know bench top room
temperature and see how quickly that
aggregates and it's something you can
very easily check out with dls
i know you know aavs 1 and 2 are
particularly notorious for aggregating
quite severely just at room temperature
and aav9 is a another common serotype
that actually is quite stable and tends
to not aggregate and you can get very
sharp amount of dispersed peaks with
aav9 the other way you can look at
aggregation is during a thermal ramp by
checking out when sls
increases like we saw in a lot of the
data in the presentation today and
that's going to really stress test
the caps of protein stability
and going to show exactly when those
different cabs and proteins unfold and
aggregate to kind of get a
picture of what might happen to the
protein as it starts to you know
have stability problems in even longer
term storage
and that will also differ greatly across
stereotypes as well
great thank you
this next question asks how would
testing thermal stability helped me with
my process development
okay yeah because i think today we spent
a lot of time looking at formulation
work and talked a little bit about how
this can apply to capsid engineering as
well
when you're looking at process
development
guess what's really important here is
i'm thinking of chromatography steps
where you have different buffers going
through your aav you're exposed to
different ph's and ionic strengths
and even temperatures as well if you're
using a
heated columns
so what we saw is
across a lot of different buffers on a
lot of different ph's you have varying
stabilities
so that might be something when you're
considering when you're optimizing your
chromatography buffer especially if
you're doing an exchange chromatography
because using the wrong buffer there can
really just
expose your aav
to a condition where it's not going to
be very stable for very long especially
in the shear stress of a
of a chromatography column the other
thing is when you're using our column
heater
some of the aavs that we've been testing
in certain buffers can start to show
genome ejection as low as 37 degrees
celsius so if you're heating your column
even up to 37 or 40 degrees celsius you
could be seeing problems with yield
just because of what you're doing with
your buffer and your aav so these kinds
of
answering these kinds of questions about
stability for aav really helps you
understand what your design space should
be when making those types of choices
for your process
great thank you
all right this next question asks can
you use uncle's dls when looking at aav
stability
so uncles dls is typically used before
and after a thermal ramp for the
experiments that i've shown today let's
just kind of run automatically as a way
of checking what the quality of your
sample is before running a thermal ramp
and to confirm aggregation through an
orthogonal light scattering metric at
the end of your thermal ramp but you can
also just use it as a quick dls check
for a low volume dlf system if you just
want to see you know hey i'm gonna run
uh some other you know cell-based assay
on my av and i want to confirm that my
uh av is still nicely mono-dispersed and
not suffering from aggregation i'm such
a nice little use of dls uncle also is
really commonly used for isothermal
studies too so if you want to check out
say at 37 degrees c 40 45 50 something
like that and look at dls over several
days
this is another good way of checking out
stability and aggregation on the uncle
all right and our next question asks can
i do this kind of test if iadictional is
present
uh so this is an interesting one uh the
result that we didn't really expect when
we started testing out these samples
if you
the short answer is yes if you're using
cyber gold and you're looking at genome
ejection uh then you're fine you're
using a blue laser and it excites just
that cyber gold result and you see
capsid
start genome ejection
as a result and
capsid uh
unfolding can be inferred from the sls
signal but if you're using uv excitation
iodicinol you tend to not see any signal
at low temperatures things like room
temperature but then once you start to
heat up your sample you begin to see
major iodix and all fluorescence that
interferes with that typical tryptophan
and tyrosine fluorescence uh so if
you're looking at signal just at 300 330
or 350
iodicinol will be fluorescing there if
you're using a uv laser to excite it but
it's something you're going to actually
miss at room temperature and it will
mess up your results
at higher temperatures so yeah it's a
very interesting situation when you
start using iodicional
great and we're getting great questions
from our audience in here this next one
asks what are the mechanisms for genome
injection before capsid disruption
uh so this one's interesting because if
you dig into the literature and go try
to check out all the biophysical studies
it's not been a totally solved mechanism
yet
uh
what you can see is if you look at
different studies and kind of check out
different mutation studies
it seems to imply that there's
genome ejection occurring through one of
the axes i believe it is the three-fold
axis but i uh i have to double check on
that um and it's kind of it's not
something that's really been figured out
quite yet uh because it's
you know the resolution of afm and other
types of
microscopy
aren't going to be able to to give you
an answer there um so really you just
left to look at kind of
mutation studies and seeing where you
mutate different parts of the capsid
what is the impact on genome ejection
and that's not really done been done in
a rigorous way quite yet
um but if you sort of start to connect
some of the lines that's where i would
look at first if i were trying to study
the mechanisms mechanisms for genome
ejection is that part of the capsid and
the impact of
uh capsid you know
uh post-translational modifications and
amino acid sequences
uh in that region of the capsid and that
also actually goes along with
length and structure of the genome as
well
all right next question can you see
glass transition in the thermal ramp
so
typically what we're talking about when
we're talking about protein samples and
aav samples is we'll use the words uh
melting temperature or tm
and that's going to correspond to
the protein
unfolding temperature so it's the
the inflection point between a folded
and unfolded protein
and then on the genome side of things
that's going to be the the genome
ejection temperature
so if glass transition is referring to
something else specific i'm not
particularly aware of that term
but yeah definitely for
uv based
protein unfolding you can see those
melting temperatures and then for
cyberbull fluorescence you can see uh
that dna behavior as well
all right
next question what is the aav
concentration required for measurable
and excuse me measurement and uncle
okay so
with cyber gold fluorescence looking at
those genome ejection assays the lower
limit is about five times ten to the
eleventh vg per mil it's the kind of
thing you can go a little bit lower um
it's just the sort of thing where each
you know genome is slightly different if
you have a larger genome you're going to
have a lower uh
lower limit of detection for a smaller
genome to be a little bit higher
for intrinsic fluorescence it's about 5
times 10 to the 12th depends a little
bit on sample purity and then for dls
it'll be about 5 times 10 to the 11th
again
all right and it looks like we have time
for one more question here and this last
question asks does this work with
self-complementary aav
yes definitely and that's actually one
of the really interesting uh parameters
that you can test out and see how it
impacts
um
caption stability so i know generally
you're going to pick your your genome
based on its functional performance but
having a self-complementary aav versus a
single stranded
av genome
will impact stability will change genome
ejection temperature
great well thank you again kevin for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor unchained labs for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone
bye-bye you